vous savez autant que moi
est-il sans issue c'est engrenage sans
fin
et qui est le plus responsable du
gaspillage l'homme qu'il commet ou la
société qu'il favorise
le bonheur sans objet signifie-t-il que
nos sociétés n'offrent plus la voix au
bonheur ou seulement qu'il ne peut y
avoir de bonheur lié à la possession à
la consommation illimitée des biens
elles n'ont que 18 francs par jour pour
vivre
pourtant la télévision la radio la
presse les responsables politiques leur
rappellent chaque jour quels sont
citoyenne d'un pays riche où l'on
gaspille
un pays riche certes mais où leur quête
quotidienne latesse les richesses ne
sont pas également réparties il s'en
faut de beaucoup
à l'échelle de la planète il y a des
situations bien plus dramatiques les
vieilles dames habitent sur ce globe
dans les régions éclairées région repue
d'or de blés d'énergie tandis que sur
les tâches noires vivent 2 milliards
d'hommes qui ont faim et les experts
affirment aux nations pourvues que leur
croissance ne se concevra désormais
qu'au détriment des continents des
hérités mais il reste encore chez les
riches beaucoup trop de pauvres alors
quelle solution faire cesser le
gaspillage des riches ou faire accéder
les pauvres au gaspillage
anticyclone stationnaire 1042000 bars au
large nord-est des Açores circulation
perturbée d'ouest active au nord du 50e
parallèle
il est 7h30 du matin
l'appartement des Valmont à Parly 2 dans
la banlieue ouest de Paris
les valmons comptent parmi les 10% de
Français les plus riches
ce n'est pas un procès qui leur est fait
mais un constat qui est dressé un
constat qu'ils ont accepté de bon cœur
[Applaudissements]
Inès elle est née des trois filles elle
a 13 ans elle est en quatrième isabelle
est employée chez les Valmont quelques
heures par jour
elle a levé les enfants Anne qui a 6 ans
et la dernière
Estelle deux ans qui ne va pas encore à
l'école
mais qui est le centre de ce petit monde
cet appartement a été acheté à crédit il
est payé les Valmont ont de voitures un
standard de vie égale à celui d'un cadre
américain il consomme trois fois plus
d'énergie que la moyenne des Français
mais deux fois moins que la moyenne des
Américains
Claude Valmont est responsable d'une
société de courtage de céréales dans le
siège est à Paris
sa femme Chantal a travaillé avant de
rencontrer mais aujourd'hui elle préfère
s'occuper de sa famille puisqu'elle le
peut
réveille toujours
une journée dévalmont suffit à voir et à
comprendre beaucoup
elle est un bon prétexte pour évoquer
les problèmes du gaspillage avec des
hommes qui ont réfléchi
qu'est-ce que c'est des vrais gaspillage
les vrais gaspillages c'est le fait que
des catégories sociales ou des nations
consomment beaucoup plus de ressources
que d'autres
au niveau des nations c'est très clair
60% des ressources naturelles consommées
dans une année sont consommés par 5% des
habitants du monde les Américains mais à
l'intérieur d'une nation c'est aussi
vrai il y a d'abord inégalité entre
consommateurs et producteur le système
productif l'appareil de production on
gaspille beaucoup plus que les
consommateurs gaspilles c'est-à-dire
consomme sans véritablement
prendre en compte tous les aspects de
cette consommation 8 heures du matin
l'autoroute de l'Ouest vers Paris
vous voyez c'est pas mal ce matin
vivement quand on voit qu'il n'y a
qu'une seule personne par voiture bah
oui c'est ça en fait le drame quand vous
voyez ce qu'on une personne prend
surface sur la route
possible
Claude Valmont est comme c'est dizaines
de milliers d'habitants de la banlieue
pour qu'il la voiture instrument de
liberté n'est plus autre chose qu'un
piège
son problème pourrait-il être résolu et
ses embouteillages supprimés si l'usage
de la voiture en ville était interdit
si on interdit complètement à la voiture
je peux même pas aller prendre le train
à Versailles
pourquoi
parce que il y a 3 km il faudrait que je
le fasse à pied il peut y avoir des
navettes il faudra qu'ils mettent des
navettes non mais faudrait surtout qu'il
y ait
enfin non il y a pas de solution parce
que aussi on pourra avoir des un autobus
qui a Porte de Saint-Cloud
en premier métro venu
c'est pas lui qui peut décider de
prendre du transport en commun s'il y en
a pas c'est pas lui qui peut décider
l'usage collectif de la voiture il faut
qu'il soit près de ses voisins il faut
qu'ils aient des endroits pour les
rencontrer c'est tout l'urbanisme qui
est en cause autrement dit la décision
de non gaspiller est une décision
politique ou plutôt la décision d'une
répartition d'une réorientation du
progrès technique puisque c'est de
s'adresse d'une réorientation du progrès
technique vers des biens qui conduisent
à utiliser moins d'énergie
fondamentalement moins de ressources est
une question politique je crois que la
revendication qui est apparue
nouvellement dans dans les parties
politiques d'autogestion et totalement
lié à ça c'est l'idée de partage
collectif de la responsabilité
dans la décision de savoir qu'est-ce
qu'on va produire qu'est-ce qu'on va
organiser comme cadre de vie etc de
façon à éviter une utilisation
inégalitaire et dramatiquement absurde
des ressources mais je crois qu'elle en
plus loin après l'autogestion
apparaîtra et apparaît dès maintenant
une revendication bien plus importante
enfin bien plus important tout aussi
importante et politiquement d'une
ampleur majeure
qui est la prise de conscience du fait
que le progrès technique ne va pas dans
une seule direction mais que le progrès
technique est lié à l'idéologie qu'il y
a un progrès technique pour la puissance
qu'il y a un progrès technique pour la
bien-être qu'il y a un progrès technique
pour la connaissance pour les techniques
pour la liberté que la plupart des biens
technologiques que nous avons produit
sont des progrès techniques minables
sans importance simplement au bénéfice
de la création de valeur pour des
entreprises et que maintenant avant
chaque innovation majeure avant que
chaque innovation majeure soit mise en
oeuvre il faudrait que soit mise en
procès cette innovation procès non pas
positif non pas forcément destructeurs
positif procès qui consiste à ce que
collectivement politiquement pour
répondre à votre question soit décidé
évaluer envisager toutes les
conséquences économiques politiques
sociologiques
écologique
d'un nouveau progrès je ne suis pas
convaincu que s'il y a 100 ans
on avait fait l'analyse de toutes les
conséquences de l'automobile
sur notre société et surtout sur la
société de demain
on fera une automobile aujourd'hui comme
je sais que c'est parce qu'on a fait
cette analyse en Chine
et parce qu'on l'a vu sur d'autres pays
qu'on a pas fait l'automobile
alors se pose tout problème de la
légitimité de ses choix mais une société
confrontée à la rareté qui doit y lutter
en réduisant l'inégalité en choisissant
délibérément le progrès technique doit
inventer et clarifier et renforcer tous
les jours sa légitimité un exemple un
appareil a été mis au point récemment
dans ce centre de recherche
international
c'est une machine à faire du café une
machine très simple d'un côté un
appareil électrique de l'autre un petit
paquet rond en papier l'aluminium
contenant de l'eau et du café séparé par
une membrane quand l'eau est chaude la
membrane se perce et le café se mélange
à l'eau
très cher de ce truc là
[Applaudissements]
cet appareil lui a coûté 2 ans et demi
de recherche
j'en avais un chez vous
un exemplaire unique c'est un prototype
mais par rapport à tout ce qu'on connaît
enfin tous les appareils qu'on connaît
ça quelle est l'avantage
ça parle de ton côté la communauté la
rapidité
la qualité du café
aussi le fait que la reproductibilité
pourrait-on dire c'est-à-dire que chaque
tasse est égal à elle-même on peut pas
rater du café puisque toutes les
conditions de réaction sont
réglées par le processus lui-même
la température de l'eau la durée de
passage
voilà et d'assister à la rupture de la
petite membrane
pour vous c'est une trouvaille ou
véritable découverte
une innovation pour autant qu'elle
trouve son débouchés industriel ce que
nous espérons vivement qu'est-ce qu'elle
apporte au progrès un élément de confort
un plaisir
est-ce que c'est très noble
[Applaudissements]
il aura déjà eu du plaisir à faire ça à
trouvaille déjà en soi même je pense que
déjà une motivation valable
rien est-ce que est-ce qu'un chercheur
s'interroge pas sur sur la finalité
finalement de son travail
[Applaudissements]
je crois pas que le chercheur se pose ce
genre de question c'est pas la pression
si il est suffisamment pris par le
travail qu'il fait
je crois que ça lui tiendra lieu de
motif il voulait dire que ce qu'il
découvre est plus important que l'usage
en fera sa découverte très probable
certainement la réaction de la majorité
des chercheurs
cette machine à café n'est encore qu'un
prototype mais si elle existait ne la
varions-nous pas dans la cuisine des
valmons une cuisine qui ressemble à
beaucoup d'autres et qui pourrait
mériter de s'appeler le musée du gadget
enfin un musée peut-être pas tout à fait
couteau électrique qui sert à couper
toutes les viandes et couper les poulets
découper un jambon cru enfin je l'ai
coupé on s'est rendu compte à l'usage
que c'était beaucoup plus agréable de le
couper au couteau électrique
jusqu'à présent on avait il est aussi il
est aussi relativement neuf enfin il a
il a de trois mois et c'est une
acquisition récente bon là il y a
quand j'ai la terre qui est très très
pratique quand on fait ses courses une
fois par semaine
frigidaire qui était dans l'appartement
au moment de la livraison four on s'en
sert tous les jours là
on m'a fait cadeau d'agril
qui soi-disant ne doit pas avoir d'odeur
on peut faire griller les poissons des
choses comme ça je m'en sers pas
beaucoup d'abord parce que il est très
très embêtant
et puis finalement le four suffit ça
c'est un chauffeur
ça je veux dire que c'est assez agréable
l'hiver derrière un soir un viande qui
ne sert pas et puis le vrai produit de
la consommation qui est sont des films
transparents
donc on peut se passer quand on a des
boîtes pour emmagasiner dans le
frigidaire
une machine à faire le café
qui est un cadeau mais qui sert et qui
est très agréable finalement d'emploi
parce que le café est toujours frais on
ne fait pas réchauffer
après citron qui sert jamais
balance qui sert de temps en temps
[Applaudissements]
un lave-vaisselle qui est alors la
vraiment l'objet le plus utile de
toute la cuisine de tous les appareils
électriques parce que ça ça change la
vie des femmes il laissait la faire des
packs électriques et le et le gaz qui
était livré avec l'appartement et une
hotte qui concerne pas mal d'électricité
qui était aussi livré avec l'appartement
qui sert pas à grand chose dans un
contexte de croissance à tout prix
on encourage des factos le n'importe
quoi
la réréfaction des matières premières
les modifications des paramètres de prix
là la crise de l'énergie font que
l'innovation ne peut plus être
simplement la réalisation commerciale de
ce qui était techniquement possible au
point de vue de la production je pense
que les priorités actuelles sont toutes
autres c'est-à-dire
elle me semble en tout cas de manière
caricaturale pour les pour les PME une
question de survie pour les
multinationales une question de SAU pour
les autres peut-être oui une opportunité
de
réorienter de repenser à un peu plus
long terme les bases même de leur de
leur activité et je crois que dans cette
redéfinition de base d'activité cette
notion
je répète le terme il me paraît
important de responsabilité sociale de
l'entreprise est capital avec tout ce
qu'elle implique elle implique entre
autres à mon avis c'est triple respect
cette trible prise en compte des
éléments extérieurs au profit ou simple
profit que sont le respect des forces de
travail toute la politique sociale le
respect du consommateur et ce sont tous
les problèmes de la fausse innovation du
consumérisme etc et le respect de
l'environnement qui est le peut-être des
trois le plus connu c'est toute le
problème de la lutte antipollution qui
commençait à devenir à la mode avant
cette crise de l'énergie
10h du matin
on change de voiture parce que il y a 5
ans que j'ai celle-ci
c'est plus raisonnable d'acheter une
autre voiture qui fera à peu près
encore 5 ans
oh non pas du tout elle marche très très
bien je suis ravi mais c'est plus simple
oui c'est plus sage de changer de
voiture plus sage de renouveler sans
cesse et toujours plus vite ses objets
c'est en tout cas ce que dit la
publicité c'est ce que disent les
vendeurs c'est aussi ce que souhaite les
producteurs qui fabriquent des objets de
moins en moins durables
il est vrai qu'une automobile dure tout
de même plus de 5 ans mais Chantal
Valmont a été convaincu par ses voisins
par son environnement par sa société
qu'elle devait en changer je crois qu'il
faut distinguer l'utilisation et la
possession c'est-à-dire mettre en
collectivité un certain nombre de biens
d'équipements et aller vers des
solutions d'automobiles telles que je
les ai décrites qui seraient beaucoup
plus durable beaucoup plus solide donc
évitant un gaspillage et une pollution
qui éventuellement vont coûter trois
fois plus cher à fabriquer mais qu'on
achètera pas je me dis elles sont
invendables j'achètera pas on les louera
elle dureront aussi trois fois plus on
retrouvera très grossièrement parlé le
même chiffre d'affaires pour l'industrie
automobile simplement on sera possesseur
sera pardon utilisateur d'une automobile
et non pas possesseur on louera une
automobile parce que ça sera plus
pratique parce que le matin quand elle
ne marchera pas vous passerez un coup de
téléphone 5 minutes après on viendra en
vous changera votre plateforme motrice
et on remettra votre bulle habitacle
dessus avec vos cassettes votre et tous
vos objets personnels la notion de
propriété élevage je crois jusqu'à
l'environnement immédiat mais vous
n'êtes pas vous ne savez pas tellement
propriétaire de votre carburateur enfin
sauf les spécialistes
11 heures du matin
l'affaire est faite Chantal Valmond part
au volant de sa nouvelle auto
[Applaudissements]
d'être contente
[Musique]
c'est la première voiture toute neuve
toute neuve
là c'est vraiment le jouet au cadeau de
Noël
c'est comme une robe neuve si vous
voulez vous allez dans un magasin vous
choisissez une robe longuement en
pensant quand vous allez la mettre et
pourquoi vous allez la mettre ou une de
vos amis ou de vos soeurs vous donne une
robe elle est neuve pour vous mais enfin
elle a déjà été portée et c'est pas la
c'est pas la même chose quelque chose de
complètement neuf qui
s'appropriété à soi en premier
[Musique]
je suis peut-être comme un enfant mais
c'est comme ça que je réagis
[Musique]
une automobile qu'est-ce que ça dit
l'automobile ça dit je suis intelligent
je suis viré je vais vite je réussis
dans la vie
c'est ces quatre choses là n'est-ce pas
c'est bien plus facile à dire en
invitant une fille dans sa voiture que
en le lui disant directement parce que
c'est plus facile à faire croire et ça
exige moins de preuve
donc de ce point de vue là le l'objet
est un intermédiaire de dialogue c'est
même un substitut au dialogue et
pourquoi il se développe tant c'est
qu'on crée de la valeur ajoutée ou du
profit sur un objet on en crée pas dans
le dialogue
[Musique]
le veau d'or du 20e siècle l'objet tra
son temple le supermarché
midi entrée de Chantal Valmont qui vient
faire ses emplettes pour la semaine
l'empathie les valmons sont allés aux
Indes alors retour la visite au
supermarché les a gênés ils se sont
sentis un peu coupables mais l'habitude
est là elle a permis d'oublier les
souvenirs oppressants rapportés de ce
voyage et puis la grande surface a parli
2 c'est un peu le passage obligé il y a
tout à la portée de la main on peut tout
y prendre c'est bien comme eux
c'est grand magasin de la bouffe et de
l'ustensiles ont remplacé dit-on pour
les justifier l'intermédiaire le
commerçant celui à qui il fallait
s'adresser pour demander un produit
peut-être un conseil ou pour deviser sur
le temps qui court
le supermarché a rapproché le
consommateur du produit c'est vrai mais
n'a-t-il pas aussi éloigné l'homme de
l'homme et créer cette solitude du
dialogue avec des objets sans passer
sans avenir et sans valeur
il y a beaucoup de superflu dans tout ça
dans tout ce que j'ai acheté il y a pas
mal de
si vous voulez il y a
[Musique]
considérer les chips comme du superflu
j'ai acheté des gâteaux d'apéritif
si j'étais en période vraiment
d'économie je n'aurais pas acheté
oh mon chéri c'est pas grave ça regarde
ils sont jolies les bouteilles là
on est poussé à gaspiller oui tous les
jours partout oui et moi j'ai
l'impression vous voyez que ça commence
très très tôt et ça commence à l'heure
actuelle dans les relations mais enfin
actuellement n'est-ce pas on donne plus
d'eau un enfant mais du sirop vous avez
un enfant crie la maman lui donne une
sucette ou celle qui lui sert de moment
lui donne une sucette et ceci ça a un
sens extrêmement profond parce que ça
veut dire que la mère se sent
suffisamment incertaine ce Badel même
pour que quand l'enfant n'est pas
content on va le contenter tout de suite
n'est-ce pas moyen en quoi comme on
n'est jamais content de rien dans la vie
parce que la vie elle-même n'est jamais
satisfaisante n'est-ce pas on le fait
pas d'une mauvaise voix alors moyennant
quoi on va retrouver après n'est pas
assez comportements
des comportements alimentaires ou ne
trouvant pas dans la sucette ou ne
trouvera pas dans ce qu'on mange des
satisfactions réelles et profondes et
qu'on est en droit d'en attendre
n'est-ce pas on mange de plus en plus
c'est le phénomène d'entraînement
puisque
c'est ça qui est supposé et qui en effet
donne un premier pas n'est-ce pas de
satisfaction quand vous criez n'est-ce
pas que vous n'êtes pas content
effectivement vous en faites de plus en
plus parce que vous ne trouvez pas le
vrai sens de la satisfaction n'est-ce
pas une autre raison qui pousse à
gaspiller alors actuel l'homme n'a plus
le pouvoir et la liberté de faire
l'oeuvre artisanale dans lequel il s'en
lui-même il ne reste plus de bricolage
si vous mettez de l'argent de côté à
l'heure actuelle vous êtes un imbécile
ça disparaît à la vitesse que vous savez
comme moi par conséquent qu'est-ce que
vous voulez faire alors vous achetez des
choses qui correspondent à rien dont on
s'encombre allez voir les les ordures à
l'heure actuelle les en contiennent des
choses on utilise le temps en le
gaspille de façon fantastique parce que
notre société a peut-être tellement
privilégié la sécurité que avoir
vraiment du temps à soi c'est d'avoir le
vertige de la liberté
et que le vertige de la liberté pour des
hommes qui n'ont pas le pouvoir
se dire pour des hommes qui n'ont pas
appris à assumer la liberté
et très difficile à supporter
[Applaudissements]
seul des hommes qui peuvent avoir accès
au pouvoir peuvent avoir
l'envie de ne pas gaspiller leur temps
et il y a un lien très profond entre
l'accession au pouvoir et le fait de
refuser de façon longue et durable la
destruction du temps
on le fait consommer on nous dit soyez
plus beau soyez plus intelligent gagner
acheter un appartement tel acheter des
meubles tel vous serez encore plus
confortable mais pour aller où
finalement
les objets sont-ils nécessaires au
bonheur
nous je sais pas je vais peut-être dire
quelque chose de très choquant mais
non c'est un peu la justice de la
naissance quoi finalement on était dans
un milieu aisé bon on a grandi là-dedans
on a continué dans cette voie-là mais
c'est absolument pas le bonheur enfin
c'est vrai le bonheur c'est pas ça ça
aide beaucoup bien sûr je veux pas dire
non plus que que on est forcément
heureux quand on n'a pas d'argent à
connaître malheureux quand on en a parce
que ce serait énorme c'est pas ça que je
vous dis
mais enfin pour moi c'est pas
l'essentiel
non d'accord mais est-ce qu'il faut sans
être l'essentiel justement dans la
société dans laquelle on vit ça me
semble tout de même disons une bonne
arme
un moyen d'approche du bonheur
peut-être nanti on a même plus de chance
d'être heureux si on a les moyens de
vivre bien
que si on a un clochard j'ai rien contre
les clochards
la société est faite aujourd'hui que
qu'on veuille ou non qu'on soit pour ou
contre le gaspillage il faut de l'argent
si on vivait si on avait si on avait
tous
les mêmes moyens et qu'on avait très peu
de moyens par exemple
ça n'empêcherait pas d'être heureux ce
qui rend malheureux les uns et les
autres c'est parce qu'il y en a qui ont
plus il y en a qui ont moins
nos sociétés se juge beaucoup plus sur
ce qu'elles font
que sur ce qu'elles sont et si les gens
commençaient un peu à se dire si une
convention a pensé non pas qu'est-ce que
nous faisons et qu'est-ce que nous
pouvons faire de plus qu'est-ce que tu
fais et mais si on demandait aux gens
n'ont pas qu'est-ce que tu fais mais
qu'est-ce que tu es mission commençait à
se le demander à soi-même peut-être que
le fait de réduction de rythme et de
ralentissement du rythme de se
traduirait certainement pas par une
réduction une appauvrissement
de la conception du bien-être mais une
réorientation un approfondissement et
une amélioration envers des voies
d'agrandissement de l'épanouissement de
la personnalité tout à fait considérable
mais encore une fois ça n'est pas
possible individuellement ça exige une
collectivité qui le permettent et qui
organise jusqu'à présent la collectivité
oblige les gens à se demander
et à se juger en fonction de ce qu'ils
font par rapport à ce que les autres
font si on devait définir le besoin
qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait qu'est-ce qu'il
faudrait dire et bien le besoin
c'est d'être
alors
j'ajouterai simplement une chose être
homme c'est à la fois vive sa vie
affective vivre sa vie intelligente je
vais essayer de comprendre et puis je
dirais vivre sa vie sacrée c'est à dire
voir que tout est relié dans la vie
alors c'est la globalisation de ces
trois dimensions de l'homme qui font que
chaque instant de la vie peut
effectivement être un acte humain qui
peut servir de modèle aux autres et qui
peut vous donner l'impression que vous
avez un petit peu révélé de ce qui vous
fallait
donc le vrai besoin c'est quoi
le besoin
il est admirablement dit dans le besoin
essentiels dans l'archipel de goulac
d'accord quand ce génie dEAN dit
quand tu arrives en prison ou pas tu vas
passer devant le magistrat instructeur
et bien
le seul besoin que tu as le droit de
garder
c'est celui du sens que tu donnes à ta
vie
[Musique]